chez julliard un roman d'arthur compte
les hommes ne sont pas des héros je
crois que nous aurons tout à l'heure
l'explication de ce type je voudrais
d'abord demandé arthur gones n'ont pas
de me raconter son livre car c'est un
gros roman il se passe beaucoup de
choses ou plusieurs actions même
s'entrecroisent
je voudrais lui demander de nous dire
quel est le thème quels sont les thèmes
de ce roman qui est tout même romatet
mme arthur conte c'est l'histoire d'une
famille qui commence paysanne qui
commence en 1938 et qui se poursuit
jusqu'à nos jours dans une famille de
paysans tout simple tout modeste
ressemblante aux paysans de toujours et
qui vivent ce siècle comme ils ont vécu
des autres siècle viennent trois fils et
le livre l'histoire de ses trois fils et
celui déclaré la fille c'est vrai
surtout deux fils parce que l'autre
également suite une vie permanente mais
de deux fils georges et ja et jean
jacques qui mêlé à toutes les grandes
tempêtes et à toutes les aventures du
siècle confronter avec les plus graves
questions qui se posent thanou
réagissent différemment réussissent
différemment telle histoire de la
traversée du siècle par de frais ans
fait le portrait à deux visages d'une
même personnalité le premier george est
un jeune homme douch qui a été comblé
par tous les dons intelligence il est
sympathique
il a du charme de sa famille il tient
beaucoup de santé et beaucoup
d'équilibré mais il a au fond de lui
même une inquiétude une instabilité
qui ne l'abandonnent jamais peut-être le
doit-il à ses études peut-être le
doit-il à une inquiétude qui éprouve
beaucoup de jeunes de notre temps le
fait est qu'il ne cesse pas de souffrir
qu'il ne cesse pas des idées et lorsque
les événements se retourne contre lui
il craque pas leur compte
jean-jacques l'homme direct sportif ne
se pose pas de question le vrai
aventurier car l'aventurier celui là qui
a choisi une fois pour toutes au départ
et qui n'hésite plus et il lui ne clair
et je crois que jean-jacques ont un vécu
n'importe quel siècle comme notre siècle
et il passe partout en souviens même
dans l'infortuné celui qui traverse le
mieux j'éprouve beaucoup de sympathie
pour jean-jacques mais je trouve que
george est beaucoup plus près des
interrogations qui peuvent concerner
notre jeunesse et à la différence d'un
certain nombre d'oeuvres que nous avons
vu et même de films que nous avons vue
ces derniers temps où on montre des
jeunes qui craquent qui tombe qui
souffrent parce qu'ils viennent de
familles d'où ils n'ont pas reçu la
santé essentiellement j'ai voulu montrer
un jeune homme qui m'aime sortant d'une
famille fortifiée et d'une famille
solide
cependant contre les tempêtes du siècle
se trouve un jour
désarmé tu veux dire le titre les hommes
ne sont pas des héros ou 10 avril lire
mais je suis tellement persuadé fait je
crois qu'il est bon de répéter je crois
au courage à la bonne volonté mais tout
ce qu'on préconise t roic de surhumain
je n'y crois pas je préfère l'homme
humain est dans une époque où les
maîtres du monde sont si souvent et si
complaisamment tendu et enseignes talent
des jeunes s être tendu héroïque à
s'élever au dessus d'elle même je
préfère celui d'acquérir qui enseigne la
joie de vivre la joie d'estimer la joie
de goûter tout simplement
arthur contrôle est pas seulement un
écrivain vous êtes un homme d'action un
homme politique alors en tant qu homme
d'action et comme politique est ce que
vous trouvez que votre livre le livre du
romancier arthur conte est pessimiste ou
optimiste
c'est peut-être parce que je vois autour
de moi beaucoup de jeunes gens qui
s'interrogent qui souffle qui hésitent
qui s'inquiètent
c'est ce spectacle qui m'a donné l'idée
d'écrire dans la vie de georges mais je
crois que il est possible dans ce siècle
qui est aussi passionnant que dangereux
je crois qu'il est possible de garder
son sang froid et son sourire donc
d'être optimiste je suis jeune obtenus
et bien c'est sur ce mot que nous allons
terminer je vais rappeler le titre de
votre roman il paraît chez julliard les
hommes ne sont pas des héros par arthur
good
[Musique]